[Music]
alright guys the finale is out there how
did you guys feel when you read where
your characters end up well it changed a
lot yeah we didn't we like have so many
different drafts like I didn't find out
the like me leaving with the box of
stuff I didn't find out until five
minutes before we shot it well but we
just we were trying it a bunch of
different ways so didn't know what would
work and like we were really doing
everything so fast because the show was
airing while we were still shooting and
I think yeah I think there was like it's
any first season of any show I feel like
you're just kind of figuring it out and
navigating like where you want to go if
you do get a season 2 which yes you
don't know but like if we do then I feel
like episode 10 leaves us in a place
where all three of the ghosts of like
figured something out but there's still
a lot of like unanswered questions and
things that are still up in the air
right because where we are is maybe
Sutton Richard are back together
you've left and you are not remember
what the country is so wait like we have
just gone in an adventure we haven't
decided the exact country yet there's
the non ism flag so it's sent a banana
- having adventures
to making mistakes to sleeping with the
wrong people and the right people
and to unleashing holy help 22 such a
blow is person member should we come
back for season two where do you hope we
picked up each character you know I
wouldn't say that Sutton and Richard are
like maybe back together but I think
we're seeing this moment between the two
of them where there's perhaps a
conversation that's gonna happen I'm
always on their team I'm rooting for
this but aside from that I would love in
season two to see Sutton really like you
know own her place in the fashion world
I would really like to see her continue
to develop herself professionally
because I think we see Kat and Jane sort
of in different places in their careers
where they both are kind of at least
doing what they're they want to be doing
even if that's that's changing for her
but I think Sutton's a little bit behind
in that way where she's still kind of
like trying to get her feet underneath
her so I would love to see her kind of
do that what do you want Jane to be in
season two I'm excited to see what the
difference between Scarlett and insight
is for her insight feels like it's gonna
be like a bunch of hipster really cool
people and I feel like James gonna come
in with like her heels and her skirt and
be like okay amongst hopes for Katan
season two I hope we see Kat on like a
beautiful island on the beach sitting
like laying in the Sun next to Adina and
they both have like pineapple you know
drinks but Adina's is not an alcoholic
that's where that's the whole season
we've been talking about we want to see
like I I just in general with the three
of them want to see them outside of the
office which I think now Jane being at
insight and then whatever happens with
cap will lend to but I would like if
she's gonna be at a country somewhere
like necklace tried to fly and visit and
then we're all on vacation together on a
bath yeah takes place on a tropical
what are they doing out of the place
where they live like so jars yeah but
also really excite
I can't wait for like cat to I will
write the show so like what I do as I'm
told but I can't wait for like cat to
introduce like Jane and Sutton to Adeena
cuz you know when you've had when you
start dating someone and you introduce
them to your friends that's like a
really big deal and they haven't done
that yet I wanted this season for us to
like have even though we had like a
dinner party with us at Richard's like I
would love to see us all on a date
together with our people like if I'm
like with pinstripe or deciding what
that is like pinstripe you and Richard
her in Edina and like having it be I
don't know what the conflict would be
and that's like I'd be on the end of all
of these sentences there's a little like
tmrc in a circle yes you're threatening
writers listen up thinking there it is
very cool thanks guys
[Music]